what do the ACLU a Malaysian PhD
students and a Greek business tycoon all
have in common they all came toe to toe
with a law called the state secrets
privilege never heard of it you're not
alone you can't handle the truth the
state secrets privilege was born during
the height of the Cold War when a
lawsuit was filed against the government
after a deadly military plane crash the
u.s. government refused to provide the
accident report claiming that it
contained state secrets information that
might harm national security about
secret military equipment but when the
report was finally Declassified in 1996
it contained no information about the
secret equipment cover-up and this law
is now used more than ever since 9/11
imagine being kidnapped
you're then flown to a black site run by
the CIA say in Egypt Morocco or
Afghanistan
you're interrogated and brutally
tortured for months you try and sue
those involved but your lawsuit is
thrown out that's what happened when the
ACLU on behalf of five victims of
rendition challenged a controversial CIA
program that flew terrorism suspects to
these secret prisons they sued a
government airline contractor a boeing
company called Jepson data plan for
allegedly arranging torture flights for
the CIA but the case was thrown out yes
the Department of Justice intervened
with state secrets privilege even though
much of the evidence was already
available to the public but not all
cases involving the state secrets
privilege have been completely dismissed
Malaysian rohini brahim was still a
student at Stanford University in
California when she tried to board a
plane and found out she was placed on
the no-fly list
she was arrested and taken into custody
hours later the FBI ordered her release
claiming it was all a mistake
but she wasn't allowed to return to her
studies in the u.s. from Malaysia the
government revoked her visa so she sued
to find out why she was blacklisted but
you guessed it state secrets are
a nine-year ordeal in courts a federal
judge ruled that the government violated
her rights by putting her on the list
without telling her why it turned out
that he brahim was blacklisted because
an FBI agent put her name on the no-fly
list by mistake instead of saying hey we
messed up
government officials spent years
covering it up
fast-forward to September 2014 and one
of the most bizarre cases today a Greek
shipping man named Victor Estes is suing
an American advocacy group called united
against a nuclear Iran or gowanni for
defamation you want to use a group that
pushes for tougher sanctions on Iran by
naming and shaming people who do
business with the Islamic Republic
restless accuses you Ani of lying about
his business relationship with Iran but
the government has stepped in they
invoked state secrets privilege arguing
that the case be shut down the crazy
part Yoani has no affiliation to the
governments so why would they have any
classified information or is the
question about who funds them a state
secret will the judge throw out
breasteses case against you Ani will
soon find out keep this in mind when
you're trying to sue the government want
more download the aj+ mobile app and
join the conversation
available in your App Store now